and Dean Wright is a Democrat he's a
former CIA officer and he joins us
tonight
so I I wonder Brian why it's so hard to
come to a consensus a real consensus
that something needs to be done and no
more fake solutions the wall the length
of the Mexican border you know I don't
know but I know that nothing we've tried
has been serious it's a joke it's a joke
that both parties are in on why can't we
just decide we're gonna take this
seriously because I think fundamentally
each side has reasons not to take it
seriously right so yeah we have strip
right we have a thousand two to three
thousand people who crossed the southern
border every single day now that should
be a starting point to say what we're
doing now isn't working now the
Democrats proposing 1.3 billion dollars
just like they did last year in the
years prior what that tells me is my
party is saying look let's just keep
doing business as usual even though
business as usual is getting us 3,000
people across the border every day now
that's just crazy
now everybody watching this program and
most reasonable people will say why are
we doubling down on stupid but why are
we doubling down on broken that doesn't
make any sense yeah so I do you find it
interesting that there really is a
bipartisan consensus in Washington that
we're not allowed morally to do anything
about people streaming across our border
like it that somehow it's wrong it's
against what Jesus would do to protect
our own country where does that impulse
come from well I think it's something
that I have in my heart which is that I
can love Jesus and love the law and the
border and I don't think those things
are a disconnect they sure shouldn't be
right so so why there are people using
those kinds of talking points look it's
about in flaming passions so that we
don't focus on facts right because if we
talk about America is Nazi Germany and
we talk about the Trump is Hitler then
we don't really focus on the
fundamentals which is we've got a lot of
people come across a border most of whom
do not speak English most of whom do not
have a high school education who will be
a net drain on the economy that is a
tough yeah series of facts for anybody
to have to deal with and to acknowledge
them to be honest about that's
especially true for the Democratic Party
which let's be very very clear here and
it
last five years we've gone from being
pretty normal about most border
solutions to being absolutely crazy
where were we having people in our party
who openly advocate for open borders so
at the end of the day it is hard for for
me to look in the mirror and and embrace
my Democratic Party knowing full well
that most or at least the progressive
base we don't want solutions we just
walk into chaos I feel that I feel the
same way right indeed right thanks a lot
for coming on tonight
good Utah's you sir